aaAAAAAA
aauuuhd fuuuuck you
AHH FUCK
Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and
once again it is very dark in my room
which means that it's time
for The Joy of Creation: Reborn.
Now this is an updated version of the game,
shoutout to Nikson on twitter, uh
who is the developer of this game, who helped
get me this early version
of the new update
which includes
both Bonnie...
right there;
and Foxy...
right there!
So this is gonna be an interesting exercise because
now there are "game modes"
with which I can explore.
So I'm gonna start with Freddy
uh, and I'm gonna see what the new game mode is for Freddy
and then I'm gonna move on to Bonnie and if there's enough time
I'm gonna move onto Foxy;
but we shall see
very soon.
So lets get into it..
*evil laughter*
Oh..
First floor: Ignited Freddy
is that the name of it?
That's a sweet name!
'Ignited Freddy'
Ignited by the flames of hell out his butthole... [ew?!]
Alright what do we got, Freddy-boo!?
Let's see, collect five objects within one minute
generic objects, they could be dildos, or an-
the timer is counting down right now holy shit
You didn't tell me that there was gonna be stuff
I don't know what obje- heEEY
OH GOD I'M DEAD ALREADY
aaAAAAAA
I didn't know that I was gonna be bothered!
woaahhh that didn't sound good
I LOVE THE FLAILING WILDLY OF MY ARMS
it kind of mimics the panic that I'm experiencing in this moment
AAAAAH
THERE'S AN OBJECT
oh god I'm dead
HIIIII
*Freddy screaming*
How you doin'?
WELL that went off to a poor start
wh-what the hell happened!?
I don't knoooow!
Oh, come on! Gimmie a god damn break here
I need to adjust my microphone
I'm just gonna die, that's all that's gonna happen to me
I'm gonna DIE a horrible DEATH
of death pOISONING
AH god damnit!
Ah, where's my flashlight?
[????] uh oh, that doesn't sound good
HEY, COME ON, MAN!
What the hell!?
Holy shit!
Uh, this ain't gonna go good.
Let my just whip my arms back and forth
WHIP MY ARMS BACK AND FORTH
Where's these god damn objects?
There's one, a baseball cap! Perfect-
aaaAAAAAAH
Oh god I got stuck in a wall I'm a dead I'm a dead
I'm a dead I'm a dead I'm a DEAAAAD
uuuUUAAAH
THAT'S MODERATELY TERRIFYING
stop getting caught on doorways you dickbaAAAG
Is that another object? Yup, oh god
*whimper*
Two objects remaining? I dunno what, or where, they are
Oh boy, I think I lost him
nope, definitely not
nope, didn't lose him
nope, didn't lose him! Didn't lose him! Didn't lose him!
Almost out of time, probably gonna die
uaaah shit, was that an object to my left?
uh oh, objective failed!?
Good! Maybe I didn't want to!
Am I dead or something?
Is this where the slow, sweet embrace of death is gonna
encroach upon me?
Ohhhh, that was an object, a mug! Okay, then I-
*feet running* uh oh
HI BUDDY
No?
Change your mind?
I understand
*Mark groaning*
aha! Fooled ya!
*Freddy screaming*
Ah, okay, he hesitated a little bit
he didn't know if he wanted to hug me or murder me
That is...
god damn terrifying!
Just hearing him thumping behind me-
I'm gonna crank it up even louder, okay
So this time
I'm not gonna dick around
This is an object right here, isn't it? Yes it is
ah- ooh that's an object- heeEY
right away right away right away
holy shit
holy shiIIIit
okay
Yes, you
uh oh uh oH AH AH FUCK ME
OH MY GOD
I don't even know if I'm gonna-
*Freddy screaming* AAAAH FUCK
Oh! I thought I was away!
Thought I was away!
'Ready for Freddy?'
Uh, I don't know!
There's a Freddy poster right here!
Uh!
Wait a minute!
Uh oh!
Ohhh nooooo!
OHHH NOOOO!
OHH NOO- he's looking at a wall
Why are you- wha- uh- Freddy?
Freddy?
aaAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAH
Alright, I'm just having fun.
Damnit! Ah, damn, one thing, again
aaAAAH
*melodic screaming*
Nope, can't find it.
I'M FUCKED!
Just that goddamn poster why is it so hard to find?
EAT ME!
*Freddy screaming*
Kill me I'm here!
Kill me!
I vant you to to eet
The collection mechanic is random
uh, even if they're in consistent places, but there's some slight randomness to it
so obviously they're distributed a little differently than they would be
but there is still some randomness to it
so it's kiiiind of
just a liiiittle douche-y
Just small element of douche
oh shit I need that
uh, he's a-comin'
Woah shit
Well, that's bad that's bad that's bad, of course
*banging*
NOPE I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
I'm dead I'm dead I'm deaaaad
I'm deAAD I'M DEAD
[really sounded like he said dad]
No I'm not, okay, apparently I'm not
weeeeeee
I just- I missed out on a door that there was probably an item though [?]
because I- I had to run away from him, I couldn't have gone into dead end room
cause that would've been the DEATH
of MEE
Alright, there's another way around-
Ah!
See that? Okay
That there..
If I go this way..
in here
AHA!
GOT IT!
HA-HEY! I WIN! I'M A WINNER!
'Cause I eventually learned rathe- uh oh
oh shit
HIII
*Freddy screaming.. again*
Okay, WELL
I got that!
So that's good-
and now I'm gonna move onto Bon-bon!
Because Bon-bon, apparently, is different than Freddy
I don't know if that's in a good way, but we're gonna find out
what way that is.
So, bear with me..
Herewego
BONNIE! *slam*
CLUNK!
sqeeEEEAK
HI BONNIE! Nice eyeballs..
Let's- I- gimmie a big hug, there, Buddy-boo!
Alright, we're gonna go ahead and see what Bonnie's all about
Basement: Ignited Bonnie
Ooooh, different area!
I wonder why they're called 'ignited'?
I have a feeling it's going to be the same collection mechanic, but,
the only problem I have with the collection mechanic
is that it's random..
and I have to learn.
Yeah! See- see- collect items! Oh-
For some reason I can't move my goddamn mouse!
what?
Oh there we go!
Okay got it, don't worry!
It's fine!
Everything's fine!
..oh, everything is probably not fine.
ooh
Hi~
Should I be worried?
I think I am worried..
ooh boy.
Alright
A minute's not a lot of time!
Make it like twoooo minutes maybe?
I don't even see a single item here.
I'm just trying to go through a little calmly to get my bearings
but, oh! There's one.
Same thing, telephone.
Great..
For phone guy to call me in the deepest, darkest nights!
And then bug me..
Nuthin' yet..
Alright, I'm gonna let the time run out on this one
because I don't think I'm gonna be able to get through..
oh boy.
HEY BON-BON!
HEY BON-BON.
Ohhh it's my old friend Bon-bon.
Why is there a security camera down here?
Is this like, um,
supposed to be something?
With, uh, a Five Nights at Freddy's- ooh
Ohh, hi-
OH GOD
H-HOLY CRAP!
*Bonnie screaming*
Whaaaat!?
The back of my head got es'ploded up against the wall
you got a problem mate!?
You wanna fight!?
Oh god
Well that's moderately terrifying!
Alrighty then!
uh oh-
OHHHH
WHYYYY?
He didn't see me!
He couldn't've seen me!
Now, see I have a distinct problem with this!
uuuuUUUOOOOOOOKAY
THERE'S AN OBJECT!
IT'S A PHONE AGAIN! *distant footsteps*
AAAAAAH
aauuuhd fuuuuck you
AHH FUCK
Oh god damnit!
Hi Bonnie!
How you doin'?
*Markiplier noises*
Oh no-oh!
OH NO-OH!
AAAA fuck you
*Bonnie screaming*
How- th- the thunking
I can only assume that the chomping is
him biting off my frontal lobe..
I'm gonna give it one more try, actually,
I just wanted to see what would happen if that happened
I mean- I don't know why I expected anything different, than
sudden and instantaneous death..
That's the phone, isn't it?
Oh!
Heeeey! Found somethin'!
It's good to have somethin'!
Haven't been able to found nothin', found somethin'! [what]
Good, okay, and then the phone's gonna be right over here then..
Okaay..
I guess I could take this as a training day.
And I'm assuming that Bonnie is probably guarding
all the good stuff..
over in HIS area!
Oh- another phone!?
Shit, two phones!
uh oh-
that didn't sound good.
I can't rightly tell which way he's coming down-
oh I don't like this
uh- oh- ba ba ba ba-
[?????]
uh oh-
Okay, I've gone this way..
I have..
*footsteps getting louder*
Moderately terrifying..
Is he coming this way? Why is he coming this way!?
Hey buddy..
Are you down there? I can't tell.
is he oN TOP OF ME!?
oh where is he where is he
I can't see anything and I don't wanna turn on my light
ohmygodohmygodohmygod
oh my god I gotta turn it on I don't know where I am
oh shit
ah aH FUCK! AH FUCK AAAAH I DID BAAA-
*Bonnie screaming*
Fuck me!
[THOUGHTS OF REGRET]
Okay!
Alright I think that's enough for now-
I'm gonna end that there
And then I'm gonna try Foxy in another episode because
this is gonna take a while to get gud,
"GIT GUD" - Cranky Kong 2015
and I'm not gud,
but I'm gonna get gud!
So thank you everybody so much for watching..
I'll get to Foxy soon enough.
And thank you Nikson for giving me an early build,
uh, and thanks for working so hard on it,
this is really cool-
the only thing I'd say is that the, uh,
collection mechanic,
uh,
i-i-i-it hasn't been tried since Slenderman,
and then it was tried out because,
it adds just a level of randomness that isn't
entirely FUN;
because it doesn't seem like you're accomplishing something..
And that is the ONLY criticism I'd say-
this is a very unique thing and I like it a lot.
I like it a LOT.
And there's a lot of potential there, and I imagine
this is not final.
So, take everything I say with a grain of salt,
this is really cool, and very scary.
So THANK YOU everybody so much for watching-
and as always I will see YOU..
in the next video!
BUH-BYE~!